the following trailer is rated ass for
spoilers from the director who
apparently gets a lifetime pass because
he made the Dark Knight comes the movie
everyone respected for being ambitious
and original but also made them say
what's he doing in a space bookshelf
interstellar the earth is really dusty
and we've run out of okra saying it's
the last harvest for okra ever Matthew
McConaughey stars as Matthew McConaughey
barely pretending to be a guy named coud
he's a pilot turned corn farmer
struggling against the words trying to
escape from his mouth we farmers we sit
here every year with greens family
saying next year but above all he's a
father to his beloved daughter Merve
Merve
and it son Tom who by comparison he
couldn't give two shits about Tom appear
all right but you gotta make things
right with Murph now well when Cooper is
sent to five dimensional space to write
NASA's coordinates out of the dust
particles and his daughter's bedroom
don't worry we'll get back to that he'll
embark on a mission to save the world
with the help of Christopher Nolan's
trademarks on the nose dialogue about
character motivations you are good at
something and you never got a chance to
do anything rather than the tiniest
possibility of seeing wolf again excites
me I can't watch you go through this I'm
sorry and dumb down analogy so the
audience can keep up if a black hole is
an oyster then the singularity's the
Pearl in time so a wormhole bends space
like this three hey you stole that one
from event horizon and the spacecraft
passes through the Gateway space returns
to normal but coop won't have to make
this journey alone along for the ride
are these two red shirts a
shape-shifting atm this crying girl and
the world's best scientists led by the
remarkable dr. Mann dr. Mann remarkable
he is the best of us who doesn't know
how an airlock works if you open the
hatch the airlock will depressurize
there is a moment smooth witness of
visual masterpiece that assault your
eyes with breathtaking effects and
assault your ears with emotional swells
that sound like Hans Zimmer fell asleep
on his organ
[Music]
turn it down I can't hear my own epic
voice one
so try to follow a law with a film that
was praised by no less than Neil
deGrasse Tyson for its scientific
accuracy even though it goes full-blown
Shyamalan at the end in a final act that
consists of Cooper taking a black hole
to a five dimensional test rack
constructed by future humans we proud a
challenge finding his daughter through
the power of love my connection with
Murph it is quantifiable sending himself
the coordinates to the secret NASA base
that started this whole thing off from
behind his daughter's bookcase which is
a paradox by the way I brought myself
here tapping out complex scientific data
from inside the black hole and Morse
code on the second hand of a wristwatch
which Murph uses to solve gravity and
save humanity then getting spit out into
space unscathed in only a spacesuit just
in time to be picked up by space Rangers
the Rangers found her with only minutes
left in your oxygen supply who unfreeze
his elderly daughter so they can finally
reunite only for her to tell him to go
back into space after it's like a minute
so we can go back through the wormhole
he just escaped them to find an Hathaway
go ahead tell us that didn't happen it's
not that we don't understand it it's
just really stupid starring the
astronaut farmer Star Trek the math of
Cain and go away Murph Luigi Aflac that
70s cameo there dick from the Sun pal
9000 and a baked potato Christopher
Nolan's contact love is the one thing
we're capable of perceiving that
transcends dimensions of time and space
all right all right
Oh what wait what be sure to subscribe
for more honest trailers we know we're
gonna get a lot of comments calling us
dumb so don't waste your time
we are rating them for you 80% of the
people who dislike the movie didn't
understand it at all I have an unpopular
theory but stupid people usually dislike
interstellar geez
you guys didn't understand the movie or
really stupid slash dumb the movie was
amazing I think people that didn't like
the movie where people that just simply
didn't get it only those that has too
low IQ to even understand the
fundamental law of physics will hate
interstellar